i think we need to workshop
the name sludge hey everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome back to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by skillshare
and we are back with another harper's
bazaar
celebrity what i eat in a day review
this time i will be reviewing
canadian musician and wife to tesla
and spacex ceo elon musk
now at the time of this interview grimes
was pregnant with their baby
formerly known as xae a12
musk that's a bit of a mouthful but i
only bring this up because that is
something to consider
nutritionally in this review now before
we get into things i want to chat about
what i've been learning through my
skillshare membership app
while social distancing at home now if
you haven't heard of skillshare they're
an
online learning community with a wide
range of amazing creative classes
for exploring new skills developing
interests and
getting lost in your own creativity so i
know a lot of people might be thinking
about ways to learn some new skills
and diversify in their careers
especially
in these uncertain kova times so as a
creator i've been taking creative
writing for all
a 10-day journaling challenge by emily
gould
now this has been so valuable for
helping me
rekindle my love of writing in a more
personal and artful way
and also it's being kind of therapeutic
so whether you're bored
need some extra self-care or you want to
join a creative community while in
isolation
skillshare is a great resource during
these times
and beyond and for my viewers and fans
the first 1000 people to
click the link below will get a free
trial of skillshare's premium membership
and then after that it's only about ten
dollars a month
and of course you can pause the screen
or look in the description below to
check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning for those
with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating
a reminder that this format follows a
celebrity's description
of what they eat and it really tells me
very little
about its accuracy portions brands
cooking preparation etc
not to mention their overall
relationship with food so
take this more as general education to
the masses
not necessarily specific recommendations
to
grimes and of course don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode
all right grimes let's start our day
usually i wake up
and it's a struggle so i actually have
these things that i keep by the bed
called go cubes that are like
caffeinated cubes and i usually just
like eat one of those and then go back
to sleep and then
slowly the caffeine enters my system and
then i like wake up okay i
100 get how exhausting life with another
human inside you is
like pregnancy sometimes feels like
you're walking into an aggressive gust
of wind
that is just constantly taking your
breath away
so getting up in the morning could
be a royal struggle so as a mom
solidarity but of course as a dietitian
i gotta say that i would suggest
avoiding any kind of caffeine pill or
chew
or supplement like this while pregnant
now one shoe apparently has 50
milligrams of caffeine which
really isn't that much so it's not
necessarily what i'm worried about
but it also contains gluco euro no
lactone
which is definitely not recommended
during pregnancy
also because supplements like these are
just not well regulated
i would be worried about things like
contamination and purity
so my suggestion would be to ideally
head to bed a little bit earlier if
possible
or if you're still tired just stick with
regular old joe
normally i just don't eat all day and
then eat one giant meal at dinner but
right now i'm like
pregnant so i obviously don't have that
luxury okay so
it sounds like in typical circumstances
grimes is into some form of
intermittent fasting and is used to
doing a
pretty hardcore fast like just one meal
a day
now there are some early evidence-based
health benefits of fasting like
blood sugar control reducing bad
cholesterol increasing human growth
hormone
levels and of course in some cases
weight loss
but i get the sense from grimes that she
isn't fasting so much for the alleged
health benefits
but maybe more just at a convenience or
i guess more so like the inconvenience
of
having to eat i may be totally wrong on
this but
that is just kind of the vibe i'm
getting from this interview
thus far having said that i am happy
that she's putting in an effort to eat
regular meals during pregnancy now we
don't have any quality research on the
risks associated with intermittent
fasting during pregnancy
one study looking at moms to be who
fasted for ramadan
did find no evidence of adverse impact
on
birth weights or pre-term delivery so
that is reassuring but still
pregnancy is just not the time to be
restricting food or
dieting period and limiting yourself to
just
one meal a day can make it really hard
to get in
all of the micronutrients macronutrients
and calories
that you need to support the growing
babe especially if you do plan to
breastfeed
and you need to build up some of those
maternal fat stores
not to mention if you experience any
kind of morning sickness
abstaining from eating can actually
really exacerbate that pukey effect
so if you're feeling off it is best to
try to eat
small regular meals and snacks
throughout the day
so on that note let's take a look at
what grimes eats
and i make this thing called butter
toast which is where i melt like a stick
of butter
um on a plate and then i like put toast
in and then turn the toast over and
like so the toast is completely
saturated and butter
um and then i put a little bit of jam on
it and eat that okay
so i'm glad she's finding something that
works for her
and honestly buttered toast is probably
one of the most popular
and well tolerated meals for nauseous
moms to be
now obviously in normal circumstances
consuming a stick of butter with bread
and sweet jam
wouldn't be the most nutritious option
and regular viewers of my channel would
know that for the masses
and all of you watching i would say
hey can we maybe like add some greek
yogurt or an egg for protein
or some healthy fats like avocado to cut
back on the saturated fat
and add in some fiber there but
when you're dealing with a pregnant
woman ralphing
at the mere smell of most foods
my message is just eat
anything that you can as moms
we deal with constant guilt and a lot of
what we experience during pregnancy
is completely out of our control so
do not feel guilty if you can't give
your baby the nutrition
in a colorful smoothie bowl or green
juice every morning
i promise you babies are total mooches
they will find and take whatever
nutrition that they want from you
and they will dig deep into your stores
so you might feel like crap but
generally speaking
assuming you're not going into pregnancy
malnourished
most babies will be totally fine for the
weeks that you're eating is kinda off
not to mention this is why we take a
prenatal vitamin right to
to fill in some of those nutritional
gaps so if butter soaked toast
is well tolerated helps her manage her
pregnancy symptoms
and helps her get in some calories then
butter soaked toast it is you said
go to bread let's see what else so i'm
allowed 200 milligrams of caffeine per
day right now for caffeine i'm between
the go cubes and like matcha
so i'm really into the fancy matcha from
little tokyo and then you get the weird
whisk thing and you like whisk it up
so i get the sense that this girl just
loves her caffeine
and no judgment here i definitely missed
it too
though i actually couldn't tolerate
caffeinated coffee in my pregnancy
myself
and also because my sleep was already
piece of [ __ ] i
kind of avoided it all together but
anyways she is right
the recommendation is to stick between
200 and 300 milligrams of caffeine
daily in pregnancy which is the
equivalent of around two to three cups
of coffee
and the rationale for this
recommendation is that it may increase
the risk of
miscarriage with one study reporting
that consuming more than 150 milligrams
of caffeine a day while pregnant
increased the risk of miscarriage by
about 19
now the bmc medicine also reports that
as caffeine consumption increases in
100 milligram a day increments we see
about a 13
increased risk of low birth weight so
especially if you have a history
of recurrent pregnancy loss it's not a
bad idea to
cut back on the caffeine or omit it when
you can
i mean usually my typical breakfast is
the butter toast
um or a fortified cereal
like raisin bran with like maybe like
cut some bananas
like blueberries i don't know
raspberries i actually hate fruit but
i am supposed to eat it right now okay
so i'm not sure if grimes
hates fruit all the time or if this is
like a pregnancy aversion
but if this is a usual preference we can
try to implement the food chaining
strategies that i talked about in my
anna chamberlain video here
so for fruit since grimes mentioned
liking jam on her toast
we could do strawberry jam on toast to
jam with some
diced strawberries on toast to mashed up
strawberries on toast
to mashed up berries on their own to
chop strawberries
to whole and if she was able to tolerate
it
i would try to bump up the protein in
this breakfast maybe with some greek
yogurt
or maybe a higher protein milk like cows
soy or
pea protein with the cereal i basically
hate everything besides carbs and
um fat like i actually dislike
vegetables pointedly but they're
important well i mean that is
two-thirds of our macronutrients so i
say
give yourself some credit girl but also
it is very common
to be off protein-rich foods and
vegetables during pregnancy so that's
not
a new thing i mean some statistics
estimate that like
six out of ten moms to be will
experience
significant food aversions and that's
likely due to rises in the hcg hormone
but if she is feeling really turned off
by protein and veg
she could try to sneak in a few by for
example mixing some cauliflower into
mashed potatoes
or rice or even oatmeal or by using like
a higher protein pasta
like chickpea or lentil pasta so to
clarify i usually go to bed around six
in the morning
like my breakfast usually happens at
like noon or one
well this woman is like ready for
motherhood nothing says
i'm a mom like a totally [ __ ] up sleep
schedule you're
normal as a mom if you cry more than
once a day
i totally get now why she's needing the
caffeine chew
no but honestly i feel like a newborn
sleep schedule
is going to be a breeze if she's used to
going to bed
at 6 a.m anyways let's see what else
she's gonna eat
i'm really into this weird recipe i made
called sludge it's like you take
couscous you make the couscous
you take like a ton of vegenaise and um
a ton of sriracha weirdly celery tastes
really good in this
tomatoes if you steam some spinach
i mean the title could use some
workshopping i'm not sure couscous
marketing department would be
down with calling this grimes recipe
sludge but i mean the dish itself
doesn't sound
so bad we have got some super easy to
prepare
carbs couscous with some fat in the
vegenaise
and some veggies and fruit so yeah
if sludge helps you enjoy your
vegetables i say sludge it up
now one way we could get the iron rich
protein and stick with the uh
sludge theme would be to puree
a can of white beans in with the
vegenaise for like a thick
protein-rich paste
and that'll help glue all those couscous
grains together
so i don't know sludge could be the pva
glue of 2020.
yeah and if you don't get that reference
you need to watch my holiday vlog
right here all right i want to hear more
about
some of grimes recipes on the last tour
um
for my last record i had this thing
because i was i was vegan
and i had this thing where i was like i
was like the only reliable food is
spaghetti
so i was only eating spaghetti for like
a year or two years i only ate spaghetti
and then i was just like so sick and my
hair actually stopped growing and i went
to the doctor and the doctor was like
you actually are malnourished from
not eating vegetables or meat and just
eating
spaghetti oh god that does not
sound good um but yeah
hair loss is associated with a few
different major nutritional deficiencies
largely vitamin d and iron but also just
not eating enough calories and protein
so
if she legit was subsisting on just
spaghetti and under fueling on calories
in general
hair loss would be a definite actual
concern
but also i mean i would be more
concerned with
things like muscle wasting and
suppressed immune system
way more so than thin hair
but anyways still i am glad that she got
past that eating phase of life
as for her love of spaghetti i do agree
it's
generally hard to mess up spaghetti
but it's also not easy to do it really
really good but if we revisit the picky
eating strategies
one thing grimes could do to sneak in
some veggies
is she could puree some bell peppers and
squash into her pasta sauce
or mix her spaghetti noodles with
zucchini noodles
to help kind of bulk it up my favorite
restaurant is cactus taqueria
i get the veg veggie burrito i get all
the green sauces i think it's called
salsa verde
verdes please excuse my incredible
ignorance i'm canadian that
sounds delicious and i think burritos
are just
inherently pretty well balanced i mean
we got protein-rich beans and veggies
and healthy fats in the guacamole and
carbs in the wrap and this rice
also i just love how passionate she is
about the salsa verde or the green sauce
because
it's actually made out of vegetables
false okay so it is
a fruit i guess tomatillos are
officially a fruit
but still that is great to hear coming
from someone who shares
so much general disdain for produce
so adding a familiar and tolerated sauce
or dip to new foods that you're learning
to like
is another really common picky eating
strategy that we use to encourage trying
new foods so if she likes salsa verde
i say put that [ __ ] on everything eggs
baked potatoes shredded veggie chicken
salad
veggie burgers veggie chili whatever you
know like so you get a salsa verde and
you get a salsa verde and we all
get salsa verde so i say girl if it's
working for you
work it like i don't do cheat meals
because i don't believe
in dieting like i just feel like it's
there's like a lot of bad [ __ ] in
society about
body image and stuff i like i don't know
i try to just eat what i want
but my comfort food i guess oh salt and
vinegar chips
miss vicki's salt and vinegar chips yes
i mean this sentiment really isn't
surprising to me coming from her
she doesn't really peg me as someone
ringing in the new year with like a food
combining diet or like an alkaline diet
but she does seem pretty confident in
her body and her relationship with food
and clearly eats what she likes with
no [ __ ] given for what society deems as
good
or bad whatever sure if i
was her dietitian i would love to help
her enjoy fruits and vegetables more so
that they're not
such a chore but regardless
i am here for her shame-free attitude
around food as for her comfort food of
choice
uh yup i am definitely with grimes on
this one
love me some salt and vinegar chips
especially when i was pregnant with e i
would have a big bowl of miss figgies
before bed pretty much every single
night because that combination of like
salty carbs
and acidity definitely help to quell my
morning slash day slash night sickness
but also if you want to know a delicious
combination
song vinegar chips with some oreo ice
cream
don't knock it grimes girl try it i
honestly think
you will approve if you like sludge
you're gonna like
the oreo ice cream miss vicki's
combination
let's see what else she has to say i'm
supposed to eat um it's
vile but just pure um and i forget why
i'm supposed to eat it but the
cottage cheese just eating a lot of
cottage cheese it's
there's some nutrient i'm supposed to
get from it i don't know
maybe protein or calcium some cases
vitamin d
there's a lot of great stuff in cottage
cheese so it is definitely one of my
go-to favorite snacks
and a cup of the stuff contains around
30 grams of protein
and it's specifically rich in what we
call casein protein
which is a slow digesting protein so
it's a really great
satiating bedtime snack but if she isn't
jazzed about having it just plain
she could try making my two ingredient
protein
froyo that i shared my video right here
where you literally
puree cottage cheese until it's like
really creamy and smooth
and you add in frozen fruit so
incredibly good
and also a really great choice for
expectant moms and kids as well
so i'm gonna leave a link below let's
see what i'll just say
this but i invented this like weird
thing where i like make a thin thing
with a tomato and then i like chop some
avocado on it and then i put like a bit
of nutritional yeast on it
like salt and pepper and it's like a
weird little sandwich that's quite good
okay so this is a curve ball but
i appreciate grimes keeping me on the
edge here now
for somebody who apparently hates
vegetables and fruit this is literally
a fruit sandwich like there's not even
any bread involved here so i don't know
i personally have never really
understood
sandwiches made out of vegetables or i
guess or in this case
fruit as the bun like i get that it's a
way to cut carbs
but like isn't that messy and sticky
and drippy it makes me uncomfortable to
think about holding like a juicy slice
of tomato with my hands
but i don't know if she likes it and it
helps her get in her five to ten
servings
of fruits and veggies a day i do not see
an issue
especially because we've got a little
bit of protein in the nutritional yeast
and we've got some healthy fats in the
avocado so
that is a whim but ideally we could
boost the nutrition up with some nice
whole grain protein rich bread
and maybe some smashed chickpeas or some
hummus in there for some extra protein
but again i am just happy to hear about
some ways that grimes is enjoying
eating produce let's take a look at
dinner
i eat a lot of like xiao long bao or
dumplings that's one of my
primary dinner favorite dinner things
dumplings are pretty fantastic dumplings
are like spaghetti where they're one of
these
incredible foods that always taste good
and but unlike spaghetti they have more
like nutrients
i also love me some dumplings especially
a good
xiao long bao which are traditionally
filled with pork but i've also seen them
done
with veggies as well so yes she would be
getting a little bit more protein in a
dumpling compared to just
straight up noodles but if we want to
bump that up a bit we could saute in
some bok choy or
chinese broccoli or another vegetable
that she likes
and then serve it with some whole grain
rice i love hot dogs because
they don't kill cows for hot dogs so
it's like you can eat hot dogs without
guilt if you
need meat and you're but you still have
vegan tendencies you want to try to like
avoid creating demand for stuff because
it's just all the waste it's all the
extra product so
i don't know i'm not sure my vegan
followers would agree with that
sentiment
but i'm staying out of that inevitable
youtube
storm but i will say in short yes
most of hot dogs are often made from
mechanically
separated meat which is basically a
process that forces bones
with the attached edible meat through a
sieve at high pressure
but also from my research hot dogs can
only contain
up to 20 mechanically separated meat and
the rest
needs to be actual meat pieces so
if you are morally against eating meat
i would probably suggest going with a
veggie dog or you could like go to one
of these
bougie vegan restaurants here in toronto
or la and pay
20 for a roasted carrot in a bun
you do you and if you like hot dogs you
do you
perfect i get the green hornet where
they just put avocado all over it and
it's like super spicy it's just like a
hot dog with like tons of
like guacamole that is not a bad combo i
mean if there was ever a way to make a
hot dog
more nutritious and balanced it would
probably be with a
solid dollop of guac nice right now i'm
not drinking it all but i love like
dark beer i guess like i love like thick
beer
i also really love kombucha right now
i'm drinking a lot of kefir it actually
lately is this
the one pregnancy craving i have is just
actually a glass of milk
very eclectic selection of beverages
now i know she mentioned she's not
drinking right now but i thought that
the dark beer
option was an interesting one because
back in my parents days
doctors used to prescribe a thick dark
beer like guinness to expectant moms
and the thinking was a dark beer would
help supply mom with extra iron
and iron needs are particularly high
during pregnancy due to
increased blood volume but then if you
actually look up the nutritional content
of like a pinta guinness
we're looking at just 0.1 milligrams
which is
literally nothing you would get the same
amount of iron from just eating a
handful of peas
as for her other drink choices kombucha
also is not recommended during pregnancy
mainly because there is a super
small risk that the live bacteria inside
can cause illness now kefir and milk on
the other hand
are great options since they provide the
extra protein and calcium the baby needs
so she's having a hard time tolerating
other sources of protein
kefir and milk would be some awesome
choices
so in conclusion is grimes's pregnancy
diet the healthiest thing online right
now
no but i do see her making efforts to
fuel her body
and baby by eating more regularly and
finding ways to get in her produce
even if she's not usually a big fan and
i will say that that in itself
is a really great act of self-care i
don't have a lot to go on here just a
short interview
but she does seem to reject common diet
mentality
and just kind of eat in a way that feels
good to her so the diet changes that i
see her making
like not just eating spaghetti every
single day or incorporating some more
fruits and veggies
seem pretty gentle rather than militant
and punishing so i wish grimes a lot of
luck and happiness in motherhood
and i hope that over time with a little
bit of practice
she can learn to like some more new
foods
and on that note that is all for me
today so thank you again to skillshare
for sponsoring this video
another reminder that this review was
not intended to critique grimes
personally or professionally and i also
understand that this very short
harvest bazaar video may not be an
accurate representation
of how grimes regularly eats but if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
me do
more of these kinds of reviews
definitely leave me a comment below with
who you want me to review
next subscribe to the channel give this
video a big thumbs up
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you